i need to talk to you about league's new
chem tech dragons because
they're a mess right now in games
sometimes something is broken if it's
overpowered or it's broken because it
simply doesn't work well amazingly
kemtech dragons are both types of broken
they're broken
and they're broken and we have just
weeks to go until the new competitive
season starts i am
seriously concerned
[Music]
all right before we get into talking
about chem tech dragons make sure you
subscribe to the channel especially if
you like league videos the more people
that subscribe they enjoy league videos
the more league videos i can make it's a
nice cycle it's not a vicious cycle it's
a good one
so subscribe i think it's fair to say
that everyone's used to elemental
dragons by now sure people have always
said that infernal or ocean soul is a
little bit too strong perhaps but you
know what it was never really the end of
the world but back in october riot
announced they were adding two new
dragons to the game one of these the
hextech dragon looked okay killing a
standard one gave your team attack speed
and ability haste and the soul gave your
basic attacks and abilities a chain
lightning effect the elemental map
transformation creates these cool little
hextech gates that you can use to get
around the map yes exactly just like
arcane i've got no problem with the
hextech dragon he's all right by me the
other one though
is chemtech chemtech dragon buffs give
you increased damage against enemies
with more health than you but the soul
buff literally gives you and your allies
a scion passive where you can still use
your abilities in a zombie state for a
few seconds after you die on top of that
we've also got the chemtech map
transformation which transforms part of
the jungle into camouflage zones on both
sides where you can't see an enemy
unless they're almost on top of you and
normal wards don't help at all these
dragons might seem more impactful than
the current ones and well they are
our goal is to add more unique
encounters and meaningful strategy to
the mid and late game
that said these are some pretty big
changes and we're ready to adjust if
they're making too much too little of an
impact so that announcement was back in
october and since then well
it's been a bit of a shambles lads let's
start with the chem tech map basically
if you're already losing a game and then
half the map gets turned into this
camouflage zone
you're seriously although cadrell puts
it more eloquently than that the problem
with the chemtech dragon is when the
enemy team is ahead you can't put
defensive wards as the defending team
you can't put defensive wards and you
can't fight in your own vision when they
walk in because everyone is invisible so
if i push in midwave as the enemy team
and i stand here in my invisibility you
can't do anything you actually can't do
[ __ ] the only way to defend your own
jungle is putting pinks in your own
jungle which is not it's not healthy for
the game whatsoever it's really
inefficient
it's a bad spread of vision and it's
easily cleared and this happens on both
sides and what do you get when you're
behind can you make a pick in this no
you can't you can't make a pick because
the vision's too big to see each other
right
the chem tech dragon map is terrible for
a losing team
now on a non-chem tech map a losing team
might try and wrestle back some control
of their own jungle by clearing enemy
wards and placing their own they would
then most likely sit in a bush and hope
to try and make a pick on the enemy team
but on chemtech maps normal wards don't
matter you can clear the enemy wards and
place your own doesn't matter to them
they're still going to sit there and
camouflage and one shot you as soon as
you go near them and as for sitting in a
bush on a chem tech map well they're
gone but don't worry you can still place
down your vision wards except with no
bushes to actually place them in they're
about as useful as an inflatable
dartboard now i've seen some people say
that the new bonus objective goal for
the losing team helps to balance all of
this out but that's bollocks because the
inability to even step into your own
jungle as a losing team more than
cancels that out but maybe i wouldn't
even be here talking to you if it was
just the map but the map is only half of
it chemtech sol reviving players from
the dead for a few seconds in a zombie
form just feels bad to play against
obviously the soul buff is supposed to
be an advantage but as one reddit user
put it the chemtech soul is the most
oppressive to play into from my
experience you have to win every team
fight twice and if you think that's an
exaggeration check out this clip from
reddit of one team having to kill their
five enemies a total of 13 times because
they had chemtech soul and three
guardian angels
so
and guess what they still went on to
lose that game now when i compared this
to a scion passive earlier i don't even
think that's fair to be honest because
at least when sion dies he doesn't have
access to all of his abilities if you
barely manage to kill an enemy with
chemtech's soul they're coming right
back with all their abilities up
meanwhile you're probably on half hp
with no abilities up because you just
blew them all trying to kill this [ __ ]
that's instantly come back as a zombie
how is that fun i don't know about this
their guide to trolling
as the weeks went on and people got to
experience the chemtech map for
themselves it was obvious just how
widely hated this thing was now i don't
know why but riot seems to have an
obsession with two mechanics in league
dashes and stealth nowadays is action
viego senna kiana pike the icarly rework
and then on top of that we've also got
items like dust blade there's a lot of
stealth going on these days and now riot
are introducing an entire elemental map
which gives every champion the
opportunity to be a stealth champ what
this all boils down to for me is the
feeling of being rightfully outplayed
you know those champions that when they
kill you you're not actually that mad
because it takes a respectable amount of
kill to be able to pull something off
with them for me a good example might be
talia if italia kills me it's either
because they're playing well or i'm
playing badly i never blame them or riot
though and that feels good with the
chemtech map though if i'm on the losing
team and the enemy is just sitting in
the camouflage in our jungle i don't
feel like i'm being outplayed by them it
just feels like [ __ ] them sitting
there looks easy and it feels like
there's zero counter play now for most
of this video i've been talking about
how chem tech is broken but it's also
been additionally broken as in it
doesn't even work sometimes i've seen
plenty of clips that show really weird
glitches with the soul buff sometimes
players get revived but then either
their lifesteal or shields stops them
from dying properly there's also been
clips of the player then being
teleported back to base at the moment
that they should have respawned just
really weird [ __ ] i mean at this point i
feel like the only thing stopping
chemtech from being too overpowered is
the fact that sometimes it doesn't even
work properly
[Music]
[Music]
look i know it's pre-season i know i
know some of you guys are going to say
hey it's that time of the year where
riot introduces new things and then sort
of smooths it all out and we're all
happy in the new year but
did we even need to get to this point
last week we did see a nerf come in for
patch 11.24 but it only weakened
chemtech's soul slightly they didn't
even mention the whole map side of
things and now we're just weeks away
from season 12 starting and it's one
thing for me to get wound up by all of
this because of my solo queue games but
what about pro play what's that gonna
look like can you imagine just how
predictable it's gonna be when we get a
chem tech map even a terrible team would
find it hard to [ __ ] up from a winning
position it would just make games more
predictable and more snowbally and for
me
that sucks a lot of incredible moments
for me in league esports have come from
amazing comebacks chemtech dragons look
like they might make those moments rarer
look riot loves to do this with league
they love to shake everything up once a
year and just see what sticks and by and
large the game has turned out okay
obviously i'm here talking about it
league is clearly a better game than it
was ten years ago because of their
changes arguably even five years ago but
chemtech dragons feel different it feels
like a special game mode except
it's real like it's the final thing
we're actually going into season 12 with
this how will pro teams deal with this
we know that riot likes to balance the
game around the esports side of things
so are they about to pull a massive
u-turn here i can't wait to see
the smiley face of sunglasses and then
on the inside it says i'm literally too
cool for this
is that you
someone bought it for me so
i guess it's me yeah does that make me
make you feel like you or does it feel
like
a you know a different version of
yourself maybe a foregone or something
maybe maybe a yet to beaver
it's like you're rewriting a christmas
carol around me in this mug